brutto kaiane lo manca tissimo mi chiese
prendevo l'altro nova avesse prendevo
l'altro era storica sta cosa per un
millimetro non facevo l'epicità della tt
ragazze benvenuto che sono video sono
farisei lì è stata investita una donna
però pazienza e oggi siamo tornati suv
simulator dei dei dlc non c'hai le
patatine nel mio m min
brutto stronzo faccio io sia facciano
scappare qual è svenuta quello sì sì
la gente si siede così perché al ritorno
ci si siede così oppure per terra usare
le sedi al giorno d'oggi è troppo
mainstream cos'è addio
c'è una che guida senza la macchina ma
cosa sta succedendo oggi è stato strano
sto giorno e vai non è mai stato apposto
è però oggi particolarmente o starbucks
che si chiama asciugare coffee bar back
è la gara della sunrise è morto ucciso
in commesso salve vuole un passaggio non
vorrei che glielo do gratis non c'era
bisogno di essere così aggressivo che
posso giurare di aver c'è una
mongolfiera
vabbè vi posso giurare di aver visto una
tipa che tentava di ecco la trama è
finta e un video mi ero convinto fosse
vera è un film mamma date un [ __ ]
oscar a questo regista ragazzi di caprio
non saprebbe far di meglio sul comincia
fin tipo non gliene frega un cazzo al
tipo tanto e stevie wonder
io posso rubare una macchina nel mentre
che siamo qui perfetto grazie ciao
cosa ho visto un predone lo voglio
subito posso anche fare i salti
insediamenti no ma c'è tanta eva con se
dovevo scoprire immediatamente questo mi
darei neanche il rocket league vanno
così le maglie oramai fatto apposta per
paralizzare rocket league mi sa perché
fatto troppo bene se ne fa vj che si
appresta a tirare in porta fa vige oddio
posso fare il salto best salto è ver
avete un'altra rampa che l'ho fatta male
quella di prima bello complimenti sono
delle delle iene a nostro di murlo
perché ci sono dei fottuti murlo nel
deserto tra fermi di un parcheggio è
parcheggio e morto uno va bene porta
starò la ragazzi devo seguire stava
voglio dire dove porta a questo tutto
con dove inizia così c'era un tapis
roulant ontap irlandese coach è più roba
nel deserto che ci siano capito perché a
parte dalla cosa elettrica
toglietevi stronzi devo arrivare c'è mai
pace
roba che vola retto ragazzi posso farmi
sparare là sopra col cannone perché al
macello con gli avvocati voli su è
troppo va beh sì ok si vabbè serviti
cambia un personaggio capito è vero che
con il suo non abbassano diventata una
borsa nello scorso episodio salita sono
ancora una borsa invece con lui sono
diventate un essere umano
minchia che acrobazia era un fenicottero
prima questo è diventato un essere umano
con un fenicottero in testa non fatemi
domande perché non ne ho idea può dio no
vabbè ho solo bei azi cosa sta succendo
preso la macchina ma qui spiega eva
peron e fisica questa qualcuno mi
spieghi cos'è aiuto e non posso neanche
guidarla come tanto son finito davvero
prima con la capra
stiamo andando magari non è una macchina
questa è la sfida ecco accusa l'altra
usa l'altra che è meglio
dov'è il mio essere umano ho perso
l'essere umano ragazzi però ritrovato la
mia macchina di prima
non c'è nessun posto dove non posso
arrivare ormai sulla collina di golf
food ma fermi fermi devo parcheggiare
sopra i no no scherzavo scherzando
scherzando schiacciava dammi prendere
sul serio quando dico che devo
parcheggiare ci fai finta di niente
linkiamo ragazzi e rimaniamo sulla
scritta che è meglio se non cambiamo
idea all'inizio la meglio già fatta
cazzo ma volo ma posso volare sul serio
ma dai ma dirtelo ma cosa ne so io ma
veramente ecco perché volevo sulla
macchina di primavera angula è un
fenicottero simulator questo in realtà
c'è ma poteva dirmelo subito rifatta una
figata d'una guerra che possa arrivare
ovunque madonna che bello che non avete
invitato che fa queste cose belle e non
mi invitate sono qui sono schiantato sul
muro ma ci sono
ma son cazzi tuoi utenti zio e ti porto
con me vieni vieni vieni ti porto io
dove sono dove vieni qua che mica se
avessi avuto st possibilità sugo
simulator sin dall'inizio cioè non avete
idea figata ecco ecco ecco ecco lo por
che va non manca tissimo allora se io ti
devo lanciare prendi lo prendi lo niente
o sei capace a fan pene salve ho
mostrato il drillo ce l'hanno trovato
ragazzi fermi può andare a scassinare la
cassaforte ho trovato l'altro dritto a
ieri dai [ __ ] devo scassinare tutto
cos'è qua no non era questo era
l'edificio scusate non volevo era
l'edificio di fianco sbagliato nello
scorso episodio ragazzi o scassinato
solo la prima parte della cassaforte poi
mi serviva un altro drill che ho appena
trovato che non riusciva mai entrare
nell'edificio [ __ ] sei una volta
entra nell'edificio vi fa un favore al
qaeda o niente non c'è verso como nonno
di curva dai frati o da cosa fa da aedes
io ho già fatto effetto
toglietevi sono svenuto sul divano
toglietemi glielo devo niente ci sono
questi ostacoli comunemente chiamati
cestino e divano che non mi fanno
passare cestino arrivano i peggiori
nemici di un fenicottero e non vedete
una reggia giusto devo camuffarmi ecco
perfetto adesso nessuno può riconoscerli
devo scassinare la cassaforte quindi se
permetti grazie sì ce l'ho fatta dai non
è vero dai ma contro cinesi o mio dio
una terza porta sito se tua madre dopo
vero dopo tutto sto bordello alla fine
dentro non c'è niente c'è stato questo
presentimento incredibile arriva
perfetto la mia solita entrate stealth
che non nessuno nota il giuro ma te lo
giuro che se per caso c'è una quarta
porta dio che è successo devi devi devi
entrare di davy metti dentro dentro
grazie perfetto no dentro devo dicendo
che ti già ecco chi giuro che muore il
mio dio dai bloccare ogni 4 secondi
perfetto la faranno i nostri eroi a
scassinare la porta maledizione se
pattino ti ringrazio io vi giuro che lo
sapeva lo sapevo
cos'è sta merda è anche scomparsa nel
terreno allora certo neanche quello
una telecamera ho vinto sì grazie non
c'era un cazzo richiamo calamità tornato
invece ho appena trovato la vita ragazzi
miei stavo scherzando ho trovato tutto
rado viavai fatemi uscire fatemi uscire
come si usa così usa come faccio
cos'è perfetto bello presidente sono dei
fuochi d'artificio attaccati a me che mi
fanno volare fantastico sai qual è il
problema che sono un fenicottero potrei
volare ugualmente prove per caso mi sai
dire come si fa partire una mongolfiera
perché non so capace gatto gatto di melo
eccolo preso qualcuno me la fa a partire
sale detta non così che cosa fai
cosa è successo oddio inglobato il gatto
o inglobato iarc josè cosa cazzo sta
succedendo è eros per un attimo sono
diventa prima di sparare mi ero
diventato un gatto fenicottero cioè non
so come ma vi fate entrare grazie
cosa fa quell'uomo migliaio in casa è
una porta a prova di proiettile
sezione di aprirti zio non si apre con
forme l'aprirsi scusa frati giuro che
non volevo giuro ma te lo sto girando
proprio io l'ho preso l'ho preso guarda
ma d ora va beh non ci credo è volato al
maggio niente ragazzi maggiolino su un
tetto senza moto in asso stato io è
tuffa bamba brave l'ho visto che bravo
che sono stati cucinando cosa cucinate
solo chiesto è non è che dovete
incazzare salve ragazzi sapete che cosa
ci vuole per rendere una festa una vera
festa oggi d'artificio credo che la
torta vi abbia bisogno di la dinamite
c'è una che vola c'è una tizia che vola
new ok va bene è detto che la torta
bisogno di una dinamica lo è quella è la
torta ma la dinamite dove stare col ecco
la nostra nata che adesso ciò la
dinamite cosa mi fai fare fammi capire a
parte che non ho fatto niente ancora
agricola di una vita ed è già tutto
distrutto quindi cosa mi serve non lo so
messa ok cosa facciamo adesso ok ci sia
un affaccio detonare l'acqua dietro
siete pronti per la festa ragazzi ed
eccolo mangiafuoco 3 2 1
[Musica]
adesso poi lanciare le dinamiti ha come
premio mi fai lancia le dinamiche che è
successo oddio oddio signora tutto bene
aiuto aiuto c'è una chiesa fuoco aiuto
cosa cazzo sta facendo lavoro ragazzi
possono perdere questo episodio è stato
un al limite rogo del non senso umano
però avere sì ma zio ahi ahi presente
che sto comandando una mucca che c'ha la
schiena rotta ma vengono una mucca
fenicottero io che ho creduto il video
perché non penso di poter fare peggio di
così ciao ragazzi lasciamo perdere che
ecco lo sapevo io ma io sapevo dal
principio che sarei viso mi fa paura
però gli regala una dinamite non si sa
mai che si diverte quello che mi sia
piaciuto ragazzi casa e tu se vi è
piaciuta sul momento è un mi piace anche
la faccia di facebook e come noi video
trascrizione non mi piace per lui che
non ho capito perché continua a seguirmi
però continua a seguirmi senza questi
fiscali e ci diamo un po stupito è la
ragazzi